hey everybody welcome back to our city
in today's episode we're going to work
on the Central Station of the city
improve some of the infrastructure and
public transport so that it will work
for the future growth as well get back
to some of the older areas and do a lot
more detailing especially on the foliage
side and on these plazas and streets and
as a whole hopefully finish the entire
island of what is going to be the center
the real core of the city so that we can
move on to the other islands and really
get this shape out there so without
further ado let's get started with the
time-lapse now the first thing that I
wanted to tackle is this very open space
in front of the Central Station I
haven't really tackled it in a video
before but I did try a couple of ways to
make it look less dead more inviting and
more like it actually breathed some life
into the city the only problem was that
none of the plans really ended up
looking that good like I figured a park
could work quite well but I wanted this
to be open so that the sight lines from
both sides from like the water prompt on
to the station but also from the station
on to the waterfront are still open and
I didn't want to fill it with nothing
since if I did that it would just become
this very wide open space in which you
can't really do anything and in the end
I settled with a sort of in-between
option putting a bunch of planters
around the edges just to breathe some
life into it make it a bit more green
and a bit more of a nice place to stay
and putting some benches some kiosks and
Grill restaurants kind of stuff that you
would see around here I'm not sure if
you would really see it in front of a
station in the Gulf area but um it's
what I figured would be the best option
to keep this spot quite open and really
keep it as a Plaza without it becoming a
very open desolate sort of Plaza where
you don't really want to stay besides
it's the Gulf area anyway and in the
summer it's gonna be pretty hot down
there so I didn't either I didn't want
to make it like the central life of the
entire city either
anyway that's just sort of the safe
in-between option now the other thing
that I want to do is actually put some
details onto these buildings I didn't
really do it that much I played around
with the idea a little bit in the last
episode but this is actually what I
think is one of these game-changing
things that newest mods have brought
into the game and I know many people
have talks about this almost every week
you get some videos and tweets from
people like flux Tron strict Oster and
fresh popcorn saying that the newest
model this week is already game-changing
as well and I feel the same about the
prop snapping mod which which you can
actually snap our props to buildings the
thing is from the game itself it you'd
have to spend a lot of time to get into
the SN editor and give a building
another function and with this kind of
option you can actually make a
residential building that you want to
have as for instance an office building
look like an office by putting these
billboards and putting all these
decorations onto them that sort of ship
their function into another thing from
what they're originally meant to be and
especially with these buildings since
this is the main street of the city I
wanted these buildings to look quite
lively and put a lot of billboards on
them this definitely going to be the the
most valuable space of the city when it
comes to advertising and having
restaurants and having shops so I wanted
to make sure to use the props to kind of
make the buildings look like they have
that kind of function as well and so far
I'm actually quite happy with that kind
of thing like many of the in-game office
buildings actually work quite well to
actually turn them into shop looking
buildings or restaurant looking
buildings and I think that's a lot of
not just fun to play around with but can
actually be quite a game-changer as well
the same goes for putting props on
buildings that don't have any air vents
or don't have any pipelines going across
the roof you can just add some extra
detailing in places where you couldn't
really do that earlier now the next
thing that I wanted to do is actually
tackle some of the transport of this
station there's one thing that I didn't
have yet and that is a place where the
taxis can go I will still have Sexy's I
don't believe
that any kind of city can be sustainable
at this point without having cars and
without having taxis so I don't still
want to keep it quite similar to any
other station in that sense but what I
did quickly want to do is remove that
road that went underneath the station
not just because it kind of clipped into
the station but also because it could
provide a way to cut off like the
enormous road that goes around the
center of the city and just possibly
save some time with that so I wanted to
cut that off and pretty much force cars
to go around the city center instead of
straight through it and also that opens
up a pretty good space over here to add
up a taxi place so that's what we're
going for here basically they can come
out from underneath the train tracks and
drive into this little Plaza over here
where some of the waiting spots are
along with a bunch of foliage and
planters to make it look like a bit more
of a nice area to stay and also we're
gonna have the bicycle shelter over here
now I was thinking about this for quite
a while because obviously I wanted to
promote like alternative ways of
transport outside of cars in the city
but the temperature in the Gulf area is
something that I should keep in mind as
well and given the fact that it's so
darn hot in the summer I didn't really
want to put too much focus into cycling
and instead make it more possible to
walk through the city but I still wanted
to have some sort of way to get your way
to the station on a bike so there are
the biking shelters to you : biking
shelters anyway the biking parking spots
underneath the train tracks and a couple
of them outside as well right next to
the taxi place and right next to the
station and bus station as well so
that's that that is pretty much the
basic layout of the new area that we
have here and that pretty much also
opens up a lot of time to add all of the
detailing and work with that for quite a
while which was a lot of fun actually
but it's it's what we're going to spend
the next couple of minutes on adding all
of these different planters and bollards
I think that's how you pronounce it
around the roadside here and putting in
all of the textures for the parts to
make it look a bit nicer have some color
in there and especially a lot of
planters and very small parks around
this area since there aren't really that
many buildings and a lot of this place
is like intertwining train tracks and
roads and bus routes then I wanted to
have the remaining area to be open for
pedestrians and make a nice place to
walk around in also we're gonna have a
shopping center on the corner of the
paths over here right in this big
rectangle that is currently still sandy
but that's something that I'm gonna get
to in the very near future first I
wanted to very quickly and in all of the
details around this area kind of see
what it's going to look like before I
fill it in with the shopping center and
make the entire area come together now
something that I also thought was pretty
interesting and something that I wanted
to do throughout this city which I
didn't really talk about yet so far is
well really the way that I'm gonna
tackle the parks in the city because I
do want to have plenty of places where
you can sort of enjoy nature if you will
even is if it's gonna be man-made but
we're in the desert
of course and if you look at many of the
parks in Dubai or Doha with these large
loans and all of this turf grass it's
extremely unsustainable and expensive
and even hard for the upkeep just
because you have to water it it's really
hard to care for cross in this kind of
environment so what I wanted to do with
much of the parks actually around here
is um very similar to the ideas of Sarah
scape gardening keep them as low as for
the upkeep and watering as I can so I'll
be filling most of them in with a lot of
sand and a lot of gravel instead of
having grass in them and keeping most of
the foliage quite desert II and
like shrubs of flowers instead of neatly
arranging a lot of trees and hedges just
because it's way easier for the upkeep
it's more sustainable and it feels like
a better option in general as I would
feel extremely bad building a city where
I'd say it's sustainable and build it
full of parks is frankly as beautiful
and green as it may look it's actually
not that great for nature to do that in
the middle of a desert so this is what
I'll be hopefully doing around the city
and the same goes for some like larger
nature places which I want to have
around these city areas they'll all be
mostly Rocky gravelly sandy with lots of
large bushes so that's that basically
getting back to the shopping center
which I built over here it's just the
in-game shopping center with a couple of
other buildings sort of intersecting
over there to kind of get the shape of
the shopping center which I was looking
for and the cinema on the corner there
which I stole from Berlin but it's it's
a beautiful cinema so I wanted to take
that in there and that pretty much
finishes up the shopping center it's
pretty simple it's not too large but it
felt like the best way to fill in this
open spot and you know it's so close to
the station it's right at the center of
the city it does feel like a better way
to have it then somewhere outside the
city parameter alongside the highway as
you would normally see it so yeah that's
that and the next thing that I wanted to
do around here is do a bunch of
detailing alongside the bus I still had
this empty strip between the shopping
center and the Avenue around here and I
wanted to fill in part of it with a bus
stop just for anybody who wants to go to
the shopping center it's quite close to
the bus stop of the Central Station but
that's on the other side of the train
tracks and especially for pedestrians
and since the bus route is coming
alongside the shopping center here
anyway I wanted to put a bus stop over
here as well make that quite fancy with
like the custom bus stop rope there and
put a bunch of parks alongside it
because this is basically going to be
the edge of what is the central island
in the city on the other side of the
Avenue you can already see the key and
there's going to be your water from
which I was kind of hoping I could do
more with but unfortunately I couldn't
really figure out how to get buildings
and like nice pedestrian places
alongside every waterfront so I just
ended up having this Avenue alongside
the water here which is not perfect but
it's not going to be too bad I hope and
it's going to give a pretty good view
for the shopping center and the center
of the city here but we'll have to see
all about how that's going to work out
in the future
I'm not really sure either there's going
to be a canal around here that's
basically how it's going to work and
here I'm just filling in the small parks
I was placing a couple of trees outside
of them since sometimes you want to get
that like specific size of tree so I
usually do is actually place a couple
ones until you get like the right size
of tree which doesn't go into any other
tree or doesn't hang over the pots but
fits right neatly into what you're
looking for which is not the perfect
solution and I'm I was wondering if
there is a better way to do that kind of
thing at least at the moment I don't
think so but it's it's one way to fill
in trees exactly in the way that you're
looking for without having to worry
about like random sizes and random
rotations too much so the last thing
that I wanted to do is finish off this
very unfinished corner of the city there
were a bunch of buildings that still
needed to be built over here and also
there is a small area a small waterfront
here which is going to be in the future
a tiny marina which I want to can't have
sprawl throughout the entire city and
yeah this is sort of just something that
I had to get back to at the end of this
episode I just wanted to do this so that
the entire central island is finished by
the time that we're done with this
episode and I can move on into the
future without having to worry about
like some unfinished areas that I left
behind also it works a bit better for
like all of the cinematics that I
already want to record so this is
religious kind of finishing of this
stuff in a very similar way to what I
already built before this much of it is
already kind of filling in the areas
between the buildings because to be
quite honest like the very public and
more open spaces between these buildings
are really the the roads that go around
the sides of these blocks but within
these blocks kind of in a very European
kind of way there's going to be all of
the parks and the playgrounds and the
places where the actual people that live
there can stay which I want to talk
about for a little bit I got a few
comments about this city in general
being very European which I suppose I
talked a little bit about as well kind
of touched on it but didn't really come
back to it much and yeah I would say
that this city actually does feel very
European in the way that it's that it's
laid out a bit American I guess in the
grid style as well but definitely like
modern touch bland cities have this kind
of city center layout as well and it's
just much more European than anything
that's related to the coop area the
thing about it though is that this is
not supposed to be a realistic golf area
city if it were I probably just be
recreating Dubai or Doha and leave it at
that but it's actually more of like
fantasy plan about how I would see that
goal cities could be built or should be
built
maybe if there would be better cities to
live in so it's not as much a project
where I'm trying to create something
really realistic but more kind of an
idealistic thing almost where I'm trying
to create the perfect city which there
is no way that you can create the
perfect city but that's that's much more
close to what I'm trying to do here it's
basically a kind of a prototype of what
I think core cities should look like
if there would be cities that I would
love to live in and think would be just
nice places in general and the fact that
it looks a bit European and not so golf
area ish is probably a result of that
and the fact that I'm just European I'm
probably not going to be able to like
get rid of every trace of the way that I
think cities work but really that's just
the reason I think many of these cities
like to buy and Doha even though there's
such modern bland cities they still
cling to these like 60s ideals of very
cars centric layouts and that's the one
thing that I wanted to fix mostly with
the city and actually make a city that's
at least somewhat walkable as much as it
can be in this kind of area and focus on
public transport and on making
pedestrian friendly areas as well and
just in general kind of making a city
where I would think I yeah I would kind
of like to live there so really that's
just a plan it's it's not as much
focused on realism it's also not as much
focused on the skyline of the city or
the look of it it's really just focused
on really I would say almost the social
dimension of how it would be to live
there so yeah that's really just what I
wanted to say about that and for me
sustainability also plays a role in it's
just because more and more people are
gonna live in cities and I think it's
just really interesting to think about
how you can make cities more sustainable
for not just nature but also the people
that live in it and I think it's a good
time to also start thinking about how we
can make cities better and a game which
is pretty much this the sandbox to go
loose with your wildest fantasies about
city building feels like just about the
perfect place in which you can do so and
city skylines is definitely the first
game in which you can do that with this
amount of control so that's really
what's been motivating me and if we're
hit to get back on topic very quickly
this is the marina area instead of using
a key here I actually figured let's go
back to a workshop I set because there
is only a straight section and a curve
that could sort of curves the inside so
I wouldn't have any issues with like
curve
that aren't as smooth as the key curves
and it's just a little bit nicer because
it also comes with some benches and some
planters and a nice big texture on the
side so hopefully that can be turned
into a pretty fancy marina at some point
in the future it's not going to be a
very big marina I also do want to have a
couple of those in the future but
especially right now in many of these
Gulf cities marinas are sprawl
throughout the cities and quite a big
thing and this is the only one that the
central island is going to have so I
better turn it into something that's
worthwhile also a very quick note you
can still see all of the cars using the
pedestrian paths which is annoying for a
couple of reasons they should be there
in the first place but also they're kind
of going through everything biding over
the basketball courts and running
through trees and stuff like that which
is annoying as hell I hope to fix that
in the future
I actually got Traffic Manager President
edition instead of the one which I had
before which was Traffic Manager plus AI
and with that you can actually block
certain vehicles from going on certain
roads I just haven't done it yet because
it's gonna take a lot of work and right
now I'd rather just focus on the way
that the city looks and just take some
boring time off in which I'm otherwise
not doing anything to fix the cars going
over roads but I'm super annoyed by it
as well just wanted to say that and I'm
looking into fixing it in the future
it's just sort of something to stick up
with right now as the city or at least
the central island isn't completely
finished but it's it's something to work
on definitely anyway that is just about
it for this time apps the central island
of the city is pretty much finished at
this point I might come back to it at
some point in the future and do some
finishing touches and maybe come back to
some things that I end up not liking as
much as I initially thought you know
it's really hard to say when something
is really finished but this is finished
to the point where I feel safe moving on
to other areas and start laying out the
rest of the city so that's what we're
going to do in the next episode I'm not
sure which part I'm going to tackle yet
but we're going to get into the other
and some of the I would call almost
suburbs of the city at least not the
complete Central Island and see how
we're going to make those so thank you
guys for watching and I hope to see you
guys next time